[Applaus]
[Musik]
is
fin
ప ب احكي شي واحد
als Leiter des südkommandos war ich kurz
davor der Hamas das Genick zu brechen
sie zu zerstören ich wurde von der
politischen Ebene aufgehalten dieses
Phänomen wird sich nicht wiederholen wir
werden die Realität vor Ort in Gaza für
die nächsten 50 Jahre verändern was
vorher war wird nicht mehr sein wir
werden mit voller Kraft operieren es
wird oft gesagt dass die Realität immer
Fiktion übertrifft und wisst ihr was
dieses Mal war es nicht anders im
Vergleich zu den jüngsten Ereignissen
Israel erscheinen die atenraubenen
Eskapaden von Doron in der beliebten
netflixserie vuda wie eine süße
romantische Seifenoper in den frühen
Morgenstunden der 7 Oktober 2023 als der
größte Teil Israels noch schlief
stürmten hunderte von Terroristen der
Hamas und des Islamischen Jihad aus dem
Gazastreifen auf dem Land See und
Luftweg nach Israel sie taten dies zur
gleichen Zeit als sie ein massives
unerwartetes Sperrfeuer von tausenden
von Raketen auf das Hebräische Land
abfeuerten das Ergebnis 3400 verwundete
mehr als 1400 Tote und über 200 nach
Gasa einführte Geiseln die große
Mehrheit davon Zivilisten und das liegt
daran dass eben Zivilisten genau das
Ziel der Terroristen waren deswegen ist
es überhaupt nicht angebracht z.B von
Hammers Kämpfern zu sprechen nein es
handelt sich um Terroristen und zwar
gemäß der Definition dieses Wort und im
wahsten Wortsinn die Hinrichtungen
Enthauptungen und die allgemeine
Brutalität der arabischen Milizen haben
alles übertroffen was wir bisher gesehen
haben es war der größte Schlag für
Israel seit fast 75 Jahren jetzt hat die
Regierung von Benjamin Netanyahu der
Hamas den totalen Krieg erklärt und die
größte Mobilisierung der jüngsten
Geschichte gestartet es wird erwartet
dass mindestens 360 000 Reservisten
mobilisiert werden aber das alles wisst
ihr ja schon die Fragen die wir uns
jetzt stellen müssen lauten wer steckte
wirklich hinter dieser Operation wie ist
es möglich dass Israel und seine
renommierten Geheimdienste nichts davon
wussten und was sind die Folgen dieses
Konflikts meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer heute werden wir all diese
brennenden Fragen beantworten und zwar
gleich nach dem wichtigen Werbehinweis
unseres truen Sponsors surfsark der
dieses Video mit seinem Beitrag möglich
gemacht hat denn wusstet ihr dass viele
Firmen wie z.B Airlines ganz
unterschiedliche Preise anbieten können
je nachdem von welchem Land aus man
bestellt bzw ein Ticket Bucht aber zum
Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und richtig Geld sparen
und sursar VPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlswertes unsicheres vband welches
z.B keinerlei Verbindungsdaten mitlockt
ein Virtual Private Network VB ist aber
nicht nur zum Geld sparen geeignet denn
es kann einen auch vor so mancher
größeren Gefahr schützen die ih n lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor Umsicht
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierf ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen NZ
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität imess erhöhen z.B
mit dem integrierten can alle Cookies
und Popups blockt weiterer Vorteil VP
ist dass ihr so tun könnt als wäret ihr
wie gesagt an einem anderen Ort so könnt
ihr z. auf Webseites und Internet
zugreifen die in den Land inreit nicht
verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub
damit schlagt die Zensur und geoblocking
ein Schnippchen Netflix und andere
streaminge die bestimmte Inhalte nur in
den USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches Internetfernsehen im
Ausland gucken mit surf kein Problem
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles W
mit nur einem surf Konto könnt wirklich
alle eure endgäte im VPN registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politik.de angeht bekommt ihr von surk
auch noch die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts vi los besorgt Z und
greift damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
spendenlinks die ich euch ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit helft ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern
so und nun lasst uns ohne Umschweife zum
Thema kommen wie konnte es dazu kommen
dass die HMAS einen derart massiven und
brutalen Angriff auf Israel verüben
konnte aufgepasst
die Gehirne hinter der
Operation achtet bitte auf diese
Nachricht angesichts der anhaltenden
Verbrechen gegen unser Volk angesichts
der besatzungsorgie und der Verweigerung
internationaler Gesetze und Resolutionen
sowie angesichts der amerikanischen und
westlichen Unterstützung haben wir
beschlossen alld dem ein Ende zu setzen
Mohammed da Kommandeur des militärischen
Flügels der arabischislamischen Gruppe
Hamas behaltet diesen Namen im
Hinterkopf Mohammed da während diese
Nachricht ausgestrahlt wurde rückten
hunderte von hammererroristen auf den
Zoll vor der den Gazastreifen von Israel
trennt sie versuchten außerdem mit einem
massiven Raketenhagel den Iren Dome zu
überwältigen das Luftabwehrsystem das
Israels Himmel
schützt innerhalb weniger Stunden
töteten Terroristen des militärischen
Flügels der Hamas der Kassam bririgaden
mehr als 1400 Menschen Verwundeten
tausende nahmen hunderte von Geisel und
beendeten jeglich Gefühl von Sicherheit
in Israel sie übernahmen sogar die
Kontrolle über zwei Militärbasen und
zerstörten ein Dutzend gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge okay soweit so schlecht wir
haben es gerade gesagt die
kassambbrigaden der militärische Flügel
der Hamas haben diese Operation geleitet
aber wer war wirklich für diese Mission
verantwortlich für den größten Triumph
der Hamas seit Jahrzehnten wer war der
wirkliche Anführer das superherren der
Operation nun erinnert ihr euch dass ich
euch vorhin gesagt habe dass ihr euch
diesen Namen merken solltet Mohammed da
nun alles deutet darauf hin dass genau
dieser obskure hammerskommandeur der
Regisseur dieses grausamen und surreal
wirkenden aber leider vollkommen realen
Schauspiels war dass weder der schinbed
noch der mossart oder der militärische
Geheimdienst vorhersehen
[Musik]
konnten Mohammed daif steht schon seit
Jahrzehnten im Fadenkreuz Israels wir
reden hier von einem Mann der vor 20
Jahren bei einem israelischen
Luftangriff fast sein Leben verloren
hätte woraufhin er einen Arm einen Bein
und einen Teil seines sehevermögens
verlor und seit dem an den Rollstuhl
gefesselt ist wir sprechen von einem
Mann von dem nur ein einziges Foto
bekannt ist das das ihr gerade auf dem
Bildschirm seht und der jahrelang an der
Herstellung von Sprengstoff beteiligt
war viele Selbstmordattentate leitete
und den Plan zum Bau von Tunneln unter
dem gaserastreifen vorantrieb Tunnel die
die Hammers benutzt hat um Nachschub aus
Ägypten zu erhalten und um Israel
anzugreifen schon vorher war da wie eine
Heilige Persönlichkeit und wurde sowohl
innerhalb der Hamas als auch von den
Palästinensern sehr respektiert seine
größte Operation gegen Israel wird ihn
für die Jugend nun zu einer
gottähnlichen Figur gemacht haben und
natürlich bestehen keinerlei Zweifel
daran dass Mohammed daif jetzt ganz oben
auf Israels Liste der vorrangigen Ziele
steht doch wenn wir schon über
Masterminds reden können wir denjenigen
nicht ignorieren der vielleicht der
eigentliche Anstifter der Operation war
ich spreche von Ismael gaani soleimanis
Nachfolger als Chef der alkutzbrigaden
der Eliteeinheit der iranischen
revolutionsgarte falls ihr nicht mehr
wisst wer Soleimani war über seine
Hinrichtung durch Donald Trump haben wir
damals sogar ein eigenes Video gedreht
dass ich euch verlinken werde also
inwiew weit können wir nun von einer
direkten Beteiligung des Irans an dieser
grausamen Operation
sprechen nun das ist genau das was die
Sicherheitsdienste in Israel den USA und
anderen westlichen Ländern jetzt zu
klären versuchen aber zweifelt nicht
einen Moment daran auf die eine oder
andere Weise war das nur das neueste
Kapitel im langjährigen Kalten Krieg
zwischen dem Iran und Israel ein
Konflikt der in den letzten Jahren zu
vielen verdeckten Operationen bei der
Länder geführt hat dem mossard ist es
z.B gelungen viele Verantwortliche für
das iranische Atomprogramm zu töten und
2022 sogar einen drohenangriff auf die
Anlagen dieses Programms zu unternehmen
der Iran hat seinerseits die
militärischen Lieferungen an Gruppen wie
die Hamas und die hisbalah verstärkt und
nicht nur das Anfang September und
Anfang Oktober trafen sich die Führer
dieser militärischen Organisation mit
dem Chef der kurutzttruppe schon in
Kürze werden wir hier auf visualpolitik
ausführlich darüber sprechen also
vergesst bitte nicht das Abo und wenn
wir schon dabei sind da Israel schon
immer zu meinen Leib und Magen Themen
gehört hat habe ich sowohl über die
neuesten Entwicklungen und Hintergründe
über die weitreichende Folgen der Iran
connection als auch über die
bevorstehende Bodenoffensive in Gaza
bereits mehrere Videos auf meinem neuen
persönlichen Kanal gedreht solltet ihr
noch nicht kennen könnt ihr jetzt über
das i-ymbol oben rechts oder den Link in
der Videobeschreibung besuchen und auch
dort ein Abo da lassen wenn ihr
Interesse an all diesen Themen und
vielleicht auch an einer tieferen und
persönlicheren Perspektive habt heute
werden wir hier nur kurz anschneiden was
die Verwicklung des Irans in diese ganze
Geschichte bedeutet als erstes müssen
wir aber eine Frage beantworten die ihr
euch euch in letzter Zeit sicher alle
wirklich alle gestellt habt wo zum
Teufel war das israelische Militär wie
lässt sich die Tatsache erklären dass
die angeblich besten Geheimdienste der
Welt nichts bemerkt haben nun genau das
werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen wo war die
Armee der Angriff auf Dutzende von Orten
im Süden Israels und die gezielte
Ermordung von Zivilisten unter Kindern
und älteren Menschen auf den Straßen in
öffentlichen Gebäuden und Wohnviertel im
Süden des Landes hat in der israelischen
Gesellschaft einen gewaltigen Schock
ausgelöst denn obwohl sie in diesem Land
an extreme Situation gewöhnt sind haben
die Israelis seit 1948 keinen so
schweren Schlag innerhalb ihrer eigenen
Grenzen erlitten die Frage die große
Frage ist also wie kann es sein dass die
israelische Regierung ihre Armee und
ihre Geheimdienste nichts von dem
Angriff Wursten wie konnten die
hammersterroristen mühelos eine der best
best geschützten Grenzen der Welt
überwinden eine Grenze deren Sicherung
über eine Milliarde Dollar gekostet hat
und die genau dafür gebaut wurde dass so
etwas nicht passieren kann warum hat es
so lange gedauert bis die israelische
Armee eingeschritten ist nun gehen wir
einen Schritt nach dem
anderen zunächst einmal können wir
nichts von dem verstehen was passiert
ist wenn wir außer Acht lassen wie die
informellen Beziehungen zwischen der
Hamas und der israelischen Regierung in
den letzten Monaten ausgesehen haben wie
ihr sicher alle wiss sich Israel und
Saudi-Arabien ziemlich nahe gekommen um
read davon zu überzeugen dem Abraham
Abkommen beizutreten und das Hebräische
Land ein für allem mal anzuerkennen um
dies zu erreichen versuchte die
israelische Regierung zu verhindern dass
die Dinge zu Hause aus dem Ruder laufen
eine der Methoden die sie dabei
einsetzte war eine wirtschaftliche ihr
müsst hierzu verstehen dass Israel seit
einigen Monaten einen Teil seiner
Blockade des Gazastreifens gelockert
hatte so hat es z.B immer mehr und mehr
Arbeitsgenehmigungen für gazaewohner
erteilt und wenn man bedenkt dass dies
ein sehr armes Gebiet ist ind dem es
keine Arbeitsplätze gibt handelt es sich
nicht um eine kleine symbolische Geste
sondern eine durchaus gewichtige und
konkrete Maßnahme zur Verbesserung der
Lebenssituation der gaza-araber und
Angesicht des damit verbundene
Sicherheitsrisikos auch um ein
gewaltiges Entgegenkommen der Israelis
darüber hinaus hätte das Abkommen mit
Saudi-Arabien auch eine riesige
Finanzspritze für die Araber sowohl in
Gaza als auch im Westjordanland zufolge
gehabt ich schätze eine der Annahmen
innerhalb des israelischen geheimdistes
war dass Israel da es diese Maßnahmen
ergreift und den drck auf die Menschen
in Gaza verringert einen so harten
Schritt vermeiden würde darüber hinaus
hatten die enorme militärische
Überlegenheit unter eernome zu einem
großen Sicherheitsgefühl im ganzen Land
beigetragen dass ein zweitägiges
Musikfestival mit etwa 3000 Besuchern
vor den Toren Gaza stattfinden konnte
war ein gutes Beispiel für dieses
allgemeine Gefühl denn unter anderen
Umständen wäre es aufgrund von
Sicherheitsbedenken natürlich nie
erlaubt worden das Problem ist dass
dieses allgemeine Sicherheitsgefühl in
Israel zu mangelnder Vorbereitung
Unachtsamkeit und weniger strengen und
vorsichtigen Einschätzungen der
Sicherheitslage geführt haben könnte und
wisst ihr was in gewisser Weise erklärt
das auch das schreckliche Versagen der
israelischen Geheimdienste ihr größtes
Versagen seit dem yomkipurkrieg 1973 als
Ägypten und Syrien einen koordinierten
Angriff
starteten ich habe euch davon in einem
eigenen Video auf meinem Kanal erzählt
dass ich euch verlinken werde man kann
sagen dass Israel als Reaktion auf den
Schock des jomkipur Kriegs 1973 den
besten Geheimdienst der Region wenn
nicht sogar der Welt aufgebaut hat der
intensive Einsatz von Technologie und
ein riesiges Netzwerk von Informanten
sowohl in den arabischen Gebieten als
auch in Ländern wie dem Libanon Syrien
und sogar den Iran haben es praktisch
unmöglich gemacht die israelischen big e
zu überrumpeln doch trotzdem ist genau
das passiert aber warum wussten sie
wirklich nicht was vor sich ging nun
sagen wir einfach dass das nicht die
ganze Geschichte ist die Wahrheit ist
nämlich dass trotz all der Diskretion
mit der die Hamas die Vorbereitungen in
den letzten Monaten durchgeführt zu
haben scheint sowohl der in Bett der
Geheimdienst der sich mit arabischen
Angelegenheiten befasst als auch der
Geheimdienst der Armee viele Bewegungen
der hammas in den Tagen vor der
Katastrophe aufgedeckt haben sie haben
also davon gewusst tja aber wieso haben
Sie da nicht gehandelt Stimmen all die
Verschwörungstheorien dass die Regierung
Netanyahu diesen Anschlag wirklich
gewollt hat nun ganz und gar nicht denn
die Geheimdienste waren von drei Dingen
überzeugt erstens dass für die Hamas die
Verbesserung der wirtschaftlichen
Situation in Gaza Priorität habe und
dass sie unter keinen Umständen an einer
Konfrontation mit Israel interessiert
sei die letztendlich zu schweren
operativen Verlusten führen würde
tatsächlich ist eines der Hauptargumente
der Hamas in ihrer Machtkampf mit der
sogenannten palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde dass sie besser
regieren weniger korrupt sei und bessere
Ergebnisse erzielen würde Israel hat den
großen Fehler gemacht als es glaubte
dass eine Terrororganisation ihre DNA
ändern kann zweitens dass die Hamas auf
politischer Ebene vor allem im
Westjordanland agieren würde um ihre
Rivalen in der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde zu destabilisieren und
natürlich die wachsenden Spannungen
auszunutzen die durch die religiösen
Zionisten in der israelischen Regierung
bezüglich der Förderung neuer Siedlung
verursacht werden und drittens waren der
israelischen geheimdienchefs davon
überzeugt dass die Hamas angesichts der
Umstände und der schlechten
sozioökonomischen Lage um jeden Preis
die finanzielle Unterstützung aus Qatar
aufrecht erhalten muss einem Land das
seit 2012 mehr als eine Milliarde Dollar
bereitgestellt hat und was Qatar fordert
ist eben Frieden an der Grenze zu
Israel aufgrund dieser drei
schlüssselfaktoren bezeichnete die
israelische Armee die Lage in Gaza im
September als relativ stabil noch
schlimmer ist dass sie in ihrer
Einschätzung der Ereignisse glaubten die
Vorbereitung des militärischen flüges
der hamase in Gaza während der letzten
Wochen sein nichts weiter als Manöver
gewesen die sie nur verunsichern sollten
und die Tatsache dass diese Manöver
relativ groß und auch gut sichtbar waren
überzeugte sie davon dass sie nichts
bringen würden die
nachrichtendienstliche Interpretation
ist dass sie für etwas trainieren was
sie sich niemals trauen würden mit
anderen Worten die Nachricht Dienste
hatten Kenntnis von bedeutenden
Bewegungen und Manövern in den Tagen vor
dem Angriff allerdings hielten sie sie
einfach nicht für relevant das war
vielleicht der größte Erfolg der Hamers
sie hat die Vorbereitung nicht
sonderlich verheimlicht sondern die
Israeli ist davon überzeugt dass
eigentlich nichts Akutes vor sich ginge
außer dem üblichen sbelrasseln eben tja
soweit so schlecht die Geheimdienste
haben in ihrer Einschätzung des ernstest
der Lage also versagt aber was ist mit
den Streitkräften wie ist es möglich
dass sie die Invasion nicht abwehren
konnten haben wir selbst nicht immer von
einer der besten Armeen der Welt
gesprochen dies ist ein Misserfolg der
nicht geringer ist als der jomkipur
Krieg ich bin überrascht über das
Versagen nicht nur der allgemeinen
Aufklärung sondern auch der taktischen
Kräfte selbst wenn sie überrascht worden
wären würde man erwarten dass die
gazadision bei der Verteidigung der
Grenze einen viel besseren Job machen
würde nun in gewisser Weise hat es viel
mit dem zu tun was wir euch bereits
gesagt
haben die israelische Regierung war fest
davon überzeugt dass es bei allem nur
ums Westjordanland ging sowohl die Hamas
als auch der islamische dihad verfolgten
das grundlegende Ziel ihre Basis im von
ihnen beherrschten Gebiet zu stärken um
von dort aus zu operieren und so den
Einfluss und die Macht vor Ort zu
gewinnen wir sprechen von der
Aufstellung von Kommandos dem Abschuss
von Raketen und dem Graben von Tunneln
schließlich ist es genau das was siat el
nachalech der Anführer der arabischen
Gruppe islamischer Jihad im Juni beim
Treffen mit dem iranischen Führer Ali
hamenei gesagt haben soll hört es euch
an wir als Palästinenser und als
Widerstandskräfte und Bewegungen
verstehen wie wichtig es ist das
Westjordanland zu waffnen aber das
erfordert Anstrengungen von den
Palästinenser selbst und auch die
Unterstützung unserer Brüder in der
Islamischen Republik Iran hinzu kommt
das Netanyahus neue Partner die
religiösen Zionisten ihre Wähler vor
allem in den israelischen Siedlungen im
Westjordanland rekrutieren und ihr könnt
euch schon denken wohin die
sicherheitsprioritäten deswegen von
ihnen umgeleitet worden sind ganze ein
bis zwei Dutzend Bataillone der
israelischen Verteidigungskräfte IDF die
normalerweise am Gazastreifen
stationiert waren rückten ins
Westjordanland ein der Süden blieb
weitgehend ungeschützt 26 Bataillone
fast alle reguläre IDF befinden sich in
den Siedlungsgebieten im Süden gibt es
fast keine Armee und das alles auf
Beschluss einer rechtsextremen Regierung
gonen Ben iak ehemaliger Koordinator des
shinbett das Ergebnis den radikalen
Moslems wurde die nackte Brust
präsentiert ihnen wurde freie Hand
gelassen und als sie mit Truppen drohen
Raketen und sogar Artillerie die Grenze
stürmten konnte sie nichts aufhalten
sobald Sie diese überwunden und sich im
gesamten Grenzgebiet verteilt hatten war
es in all dem Chaos dann sehr schwer sie
ausfindig zu machen und zu eliminieren
und genau damit hatten sie gerechnet ein
iranischer general hatte diesen Plan
sogar vor einem Jahr offenelegt und
trotzdem brauchten die IDF zwischen 6
und fast 10 Stunden bis ausreichend
Truppen in die besetzten Orte gebracht
werden konnten eine
Katastrophe okay jetzt da wir wissen wie
die Hamas mit ihrem brutalen Angriff
durchkommen konnte bleibt die große
Frage zu beantworten warum was war der
Zweck dieser ganzen Aktion nun ja das
ist ein äußerst umfangreiches Thema und
ich habe es wie gesagt schon auf meinem
persönlichen Kanal ausführlich behandelt
es scheint ziemlich klar zu sein dass
das Hauptziel der Operation darin
bestand das Abkommen zwischen Israel den
USA und Saudi-Arabien zu vereiteln denn
damit wäre Saudi-Arabien dem sogenannten
Abraham Abkommen beigetreten einem
Abkommen dass die Beziehungen der
arabischen Großmacht Nummer 1 mit dem
Hebräischen Land normalisieren würde
doch die arabe in Gaza als auch im
Westjordanland hatten viele Jahre über
auf die Solidarität der groß arabischen
Mächte vertraut und eben darauf dass
diese Israel permanent unter Druck
setzen würden doch aufgrund der
dauernden Eskapaden und des opferkuls
der radikalen waren sie immer weniger
dazu bereit vor allem die Jungen
herrschergeneration die endlich nach
vorne blicken und ihre Länder
modernisieren wollen diese Entwicklung
war ein schwerer Schlag für die Hamas
aber vor allem auch für den Iran und
wahrscheinlich auch für Russland auf dem
Tisch lag ein neues Sicherheitsabkommen
und vielleicht auch eine Erhöhung der
Ölproduktion die Zukunft ist derzeit
also ungewisser den je es bleibt
abzuwarten was mit den Geiseln passiert
die Möglichkeit einer zweiatenlösung
könnte für Jahrzehnte entgleist sein und
was noch beunruhigender ist sollte die
hisbalah Israel angreifen könnte das
einen großen regionalen Konflikt
auflösen natürlich werden wir am Thema
dran bleiben und euch in zukünftigen
Videos auf dem Laufenden halten hier auf
visualpolitik und auf meinem neuen
persönlichen Kanal den ihr euch jetzt
unbedingt ansehen solltet falls ih noch
nicht kennt wie immer hoffe ich dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like teilt
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ih natürlich freuen wir uns auch wie
gesagt jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit dies Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut schalom und
bis
[Musik]
bald